Two one. Boom. Ms Pat, we're live. What's up? How are you? Hey,
great to see you again. Glad to be back, man.
This studio is better than my house. Crap.
I'm gonna go home and tell eyes we need to move in. Joe Rogan's studio.
There's not a lot of room for extra people. I know, I know. I know.
I was just fantasizing, but he's still in Indianapolis. Um,
unfortunately you don't like it there. Hell No.
I like my fans, but I'm, I'm black and then you know,
as snow and snow and we've don't go together and you know,
I just don't like it.
It's the same or everybody that Applebee's and golden corral. I need culture,
Cultural Chicago. I'm cool. I want to go back to Atlanta. Atlanta.
That's where I want to be. I want to be in Atlanta. I love Atlanta. Yes man.
The food, the people. Oh, I just,
I want to walk up my Dole and smell Mexican Indian. All type of spices.
I'll ask the mail in my community is dog shit and ticket torches.
Cause why women do they laundry? Dryer sheets. I need some culture.
I need to walk outside and see all types of people.
This isn't a weird how places just never develop a lot of culture.
Some places just the spots just never get any more. Interesting. Yeah,
it's just, it's so boring. Everybody goes to church, nobody curves.
And when I come on my door and if I'm talking to a neighbor and I use
professional, oh my God,
I said I'm not going to change my language because you decided to walk your dog
today and stop and talk to me and you've tried to talk to me and everybody
picked up big dog shit in my community and well from, hey,
that was fertilizer.
So you see your name on a big old pound of doll crap in his hand. I'm like,
dude, no, no, I don't think it works as fertilizer.
It was my dog pisses and shits on the lawn just leaves these big old like yellow
spans. But if you leave it long enough and it rains on,
they just go into the grave. That's true. They don't kill the gray.
Don't kill the grass. I did the pistis. The piss seems to kill the grass. Well,
I don't know. We didn't have no grass. Everybody walked through the grass.
I just didn't care about it. Loans until I bought came became a homeowner. Yeah.
Homeowners care about lawns. Homeowners care about a lot of crap. You have to,
yeah, I have a rental property in Atlanta. If I can get rid of that,
I would never, ever black people come up with some of the strangest things.
What ain't got they rent like as opposed to care.
I tell them bank of America don't care that your Mama that y'all do your
grandchild had a seizure. I need my rent money. Put a spoon in his mouth.
Tell them about seatbelt. Yeah, I mean I've had some,
oh, I just gotta be so glad when I can get rid of this property.
You own a place in Atlanta? Yes. Would you live there at the place he own?
Hell No. No, no. I wouldn't live there.
I'm a little too boozy for that bullshit.
No, not too much that says I'm going to look Booz. You didn't live back well,
but I rent it out. I ran out some nice place.
But you would live in Atlanta somewhere else. Oh yeah.
I want to go to Peachtree city. Kennesaw. Yeah. I want to live in Atlanta.
I love Atlanta. Why don't you make your way down there? What's,
what's your old new and then the Apple's health care. Jail. Health care.
My husband has a really good job that we pay nothing. His knee just went out.
His hands down, gone out and I can't pay for them. Types of things. What?
Damn. He tore his ACL run into the cafeteria at work. Oh yeah. I've done a,
I've done a tour. Both of them. You probably were exercising.
He was going to get food.
Don't watch his episode of Joe Rogan Baby. I'm sorry.
That's a rough one. Recover from it takes six months.
He was six months now he's, he got a cup of Tony in his hands.
So he's getting ready to have a hand surgeon type. What does he, uh,
he builds the Alison transmission for Alison. Oh,
General Motors and always constantly moving things with his hands.
So his hand is out. O'Connell's a bitch. My mom got that. That's a rough one.
Well, I've never had a job where I did that much repetition. You know,
I sold drugs and forge a few checks. It wasn't an everyday thing.
I had to do so many checks. You have to forge for your carpal tunnel. Oh yeah,
a lot. So once you burn 32 you don't have any mo to burn.
You got to wait till somebody steal the next book.
Plus I was really young back in the day. Yeah. Damn.
So that's what's keeping you in. Annapolis husband had a good job.
I needed a TV show so I can get some really good health care.
Your podcast is launched now. It is. It's called the pat down, the pat down.
And I have my own song too. Yes.
We're talking about Ra getting in trouble for putting other people's songs on
his podcast and demonetizing his podcast. Yeah, my nephew,
I'm a Riverdale shouted, made me my own little pat down son. Oh, nice.
So yeah. So somebody made a song for you that's, yeah, yeah.
I was just trying to do something different.
It's only 30 minutes of me talking crap about whatever's going on in my life.
You hit, you hit my kids in the background getting cussed out,
you hit a credit,
a calling me and my cohost is a little white boy named Chris who don't know
nothing about black America. And then I got my friend who just ah, AH,
he ready to go march if you, if you need him to. So I got,
I got this libertarian,
this crazy as Democrat together and I'm down the middle and say, hey,
we can all get along. And they hated each other. Then first,
how'd you get them together? Because they hated each other.
She did it on purpose. Yeah. My black friend thought Chris was racist.
I was like, no, I know racist. He's not racist. He just not eve to the fat.
And so I put them, not EAD. You've done tell him what I'm trying to say. Naive.
Oh, naive. Naive. Yeah. You got to translate. I was like, yeah, no,
like Adam and eve trying to go with this [inaudible] eat.
But it sounded Adam and eve. Yes. So it, he just didn't understand.
So we get them together. We have these conversation about race and uh,
we did an episode about a bullshit and Chris was like, he's really Christian.
And he was like, I was like,
do you believe a woman should have a right to have an abortion?
He just pitter patter all around. So it's Chris just say yes. A fucking no.
And finally said, I don't believe a woman should have an abortion. I said,
well that's fine, but this is my vagina and I can do what I want to do with,
if I want to stick five crackers in my vagina and turn it into the 4th of July,
Joe Rogan, this is my vagina. As long as I don't get no vaginal juice on you.
That makes sense. Yeah. Atlanta's got a problem now with that. Right.
There's nothing. Georgia just passed a new abortion law.
I don't think it's passed yet, but they say she just canceled her shows. Yeah.
Yeah. She's canceled her shows in Atlanta because I think it passed.
I think that was the idea. That's why she canceled it.
I don't think he passed Joe Cause the TV people haven't pulled out yet.
Oh yeah it would if it passed. I think they would.
I really think they got money that Atlanta got them in there because of tax
money. Yeah. And I think they're leaving it.
Get a lot of people lose their jobs. I don't think they're going to leave.
I don't think the money should be telling us what to do with our bodies.
I don't think so either. Yeah,
that mean that you know I been shot in the t that my one messed up.
So that's like you trying to tell me I should get my TD fixed.
If I don't want my titty fixed, it's my prerogative.
I shouldn't have to have my titty fix. Right. Joe,
how do you feel about late term abortions? That's where people get scared. They,
I don't think, yeah, I don't think you should be killing,
don't have an abortion and no,
six and eight months now and I don't think it should be recreation either cause
I had an abortion. They just doing it for fun. Recreation.
I like that you translate. Oh, I've had a few friends.
What are you going to do today? I was thinking about riding a roller coaster,
but fuck it, I'll get an abortion.
I've had a few friends that had quite a few boys that I've had one myself.
I mean my, in my situation, I think everybody's situation is different.
My situation I was,
I already had my first baby at 14 my second child at 15 and it was by a married
man. Well, I got pregnant by his married man again and I just looked at myself,
I said, here I am 16 pray do with my third child.
I cannot take care of the two hour gap. And you know,
it wasn't all of this stuff like what they tell you about birth control and safe
sex that wasn't going on in the eighties you know,
people shutting their doors and talking wouldn't even talk about it.
Especially when you were a little kid. I'm 14 so I was a little kid.
I was a kid. So when I got pregnant with my third child, I w I became a master,
paid in minor in divorce.
My mom and I went and got an abortion because I knew he wasn't helping me with
the first two so crazy.
So I couldn't take it on the first part because still to this day,
sometimes I'll be doing something and I'll just think about your story in the
scope.
So on drugs as a teenager,
pregnant with two kids by the time you're 16 [inaudible] crazy in jail.
I mean I dropped out of school in the eighth grade, you know, all this stuff.
And I just say, I
said I don't want my kids eating them like me. So I was like,
I can't keep having these babies.
And after that I got on birth control and I just prayed. I said, Lord,
I don't want no more kids by this bomb. And I never got pregnant.
So I got married. Well that's good. Yeah. So now I have those too. You know,
I used to tell a bit about,
I got a set of Medicaid kids and instead of blue cross blue shield kids,
so I waited till they got older. I mean I got older and I became,
I started to learn about life.
He taught me a lot and so I had those last two and I tied my tunes. Very,
very good move for is more than, that's a good number.
But you know Joe, I'm black.
So when my family smoked crack so they keep giving me their kids.
So I had to tie my tubes to make room for the crack baby.
They keep coming in and not my house. I'm raising for rent now. Yeah,
I have my niece, my niece, my,
I picked up my niece like five years ago to help her out. Oh,
she had a baby that was two weeks old and I have this thing like, oh,
kids deserve off solid foundation because I didn't have one. So I picked,
this is my third set of kids I've raised and I'm just 47 so I picked my niece up
maybe two weeks old and she got three other kids. I said, okay,
I got this big house in Indianapolis, come live with me. I got three,
four extra bedrooms. Well this bitch ran off and left me with them kid.
Now I have a five or eight. Yeah.
On a 10 and 11 year old and I've had these kids for six years and I literally
have not seen my niece in almost four years. No phone call,
no nothing. And you know, I'm trying to build a career.
So I have a daughter who, my whole,
my kids who were at the house and they had to make a major sacrifice.
Like my daughter couldn't go off to college because she didn't want to leave my
husband with these four kids. So she went to college in Indianapolis,
but she stayed, she went mostly from, you know, home.
My son couldn't go off to college because they at home helping them raise the
four kids that I called my crack babies but at home raising my crack babies
because you don't want to leave my husband all 14 crack babies by the sales.
So you know, where's the mother? You want to hear some crazy,
the bitch blocked me on Facebook joke.
She won't even let me be a friend on Facebook. You taking care of her children.
She blocked you on Facebook once she block you. Cause I kept saying,
I'm a kill you bitch. I,
I was ready to live my best life. I was like, well I'm making some money.
Me and my husband go to Hawaii getting naked, floating in the water, Bam,
full crack babies. You can't do that when you can't.
You know how much you're taking. The how, why you call. I can't take them crazy.
Oh my God, I love the phrase yell.
So I mean it changed. It's changed everything. And then, you know,
when she left and she didn't even give me custody,
I had to go and hire this lawyer and go and get custody because she just ran
off. And I asked the, you know, the welfare
system in Indianapolis. I said,
can y'all just give me childcare because childcare was going to be like $800 a
week because my kids was in high school when she loved. And they was like, no,
we can't give you that,
but we will give you medicaid and $300 they get, they didn't,
they didn't give me shit. Jesus Christ. So I just, I just made away my,
and I said, you know what, I've had this baby since she was two weeks old.
How do you drop a baby that you've had since she was two weeks old?
Your baby now? Yeah. You can't, I can't give up. I love are
so fucking crazy. The mother blocked you? No.
Oh my God. No. But we did make a secret account. Right?
Have a nice fine man like yourself. Joe Rogan. Nice fine black man. And we, we,
we friended her so she accepted as a friend so she don't know that that's us.
And she only saw your podcast so I can tell. So we follow her like that.
So she's on the other side of town getting high. Oh, never hit me up.
Never talk about the kids. You know, I don't get a dime from nobody.
Nobody and don't ask for nothing. I mean, I'm just at this point,
I'm thankful that I can even take care of these kids.
Cause my sister was on drugs and I took care of her keys. My niece was on drugs.
Now. I took care of them for 10 years with my husband and she's on drugs now.
The daughter is on drugs.
When my sister got them back and got them my own drugs, like her, Jesus Christ.
So I made sure that these kids can go back to that situation.
Now I call him my Bougie crack babies.
They won't even eat McDonald's only Chick-Filet.
They're like, oh, we don't eat McDonald's. We eat chick fillet. And I was like,
I remember when your ass and eat at all babies.
They give me great material, but it's not easy. But um, you know,
you call them crack babies? No, they don't.
My husband stop calling them kids crack. Bang.
They don't know. I call them crack babies. Only America know that.
I call them crack babies, but y'all can't call them crack babies. Oh my God.
Did they call your mom? Uh, they do and his count on weird.
So they just started calling me mom out of nowhere and I'm like,
don't come in fucking Mama Auntie. And, but then now I just let them go.
Beautiful. Well, they go to school and they see all the, you know,
I live in this white community. They see all these kids with a mom and Daddy.
And they was like, well, why don't we have,
and they just started calling me mom and so were mom and my daughter who um,
she just graduated from college, but she's, they got two moms and then my dad,
my husband is a their daddy. Yeah. Well thank you. Thank you.
Beautiful thing you're doing. It really is.
Even though the ladies know in the black woman, she's a bitch.
She, that's what she, those kids got lucky. They got lucky. They really did.
I took them on a Disney cruise last year, Joe and Oh my God,
they had the time of day lives and look at my Craig baby.
They don't know what, I don't say them from the cry. Oh my God,
what you saved this from. And they're on a Disney cruise.
I was looking at Craig bavel Indian cruise with matching outfits,
but I love him. I mean, raising that you're doing that. It really is. I mean,
I know it's hard, but it's amazing that you're doing that. Well, you know,
like I said earlier, every,
every child deserves a solid foundation to start off. Unfortunately for me,
I didn't have that solid foundation.
I didn't have nobody to step in my life and you know, snatch me from my mom.
But you know, whenever I see a child in need, especially a family member,
I always try to step in because I know,
I know when you don't have that solid foundation where you can end up and some
kids in, you know, fucked up even with a solid foundation.
But if you can give them a good start, at least give them a good start.
And that's all I ever wanted to do. That's beautiful. Yeah.
And seven's learning center is killing me.
I put the black crack babies in this white community.
Kids been reading since they were two.
They were whooping my black ass as Joe Joe Rogan, the tutors.
I'm like, I'm thinking I'll come along. I'm like, Oh,
I be glad when you crack babies catch up. I'll be glad when y'all catch up.
We gotta get this podcast take off. Yes, yes, yes. Well,
I don't lead a TV show these days.
You don't just need that podcast to keep going. I know. And I'm enjoying it too.
I didn't. You're perfect for it. Like that's what we were talking about,
the comedy story last time I saw him four o'clock in the morning, I was like,
you've got to, you have to write. You write. And I really like it too.
I knew you. I was like, this doesn't make any sense that you don't have one.
Yup. And I mean, I'm enjoying it. 30 minutes they'd go, Oh, Ms Pat,
give me more. I'm like, excuse me, I'm sitting here with no wig on. No Bra.
He took no bath and Chris might be smelling me after 35 minutes.
This is all you going to get. Plus, you know,
he come over at four three o'clock and then my baby's coming in the door at four
o'clock so I'm gonna sit gas down.
I'm screaming and hollered and I got to go fix food and I got a life.
I'm married. I can't sit there for, you know, drama, this is fine.
And I like it. As long as you're consistent, that's the whole thing.
It's like be consistent. Don't take weeks off. Like when,
when people take like four weeks off, five weeks off, people forget.
And then they're not interested in your podcasts anymore. But if you,
if you're just consistent, you just keep doing it. People get,
it becomes a part of their routine and then they tell people you got to listen
to miss path's podcast and next thing you know by word of mouth,
it just spreads. Yeah. And I mean we have so many episodes in the bank.
How many of you have, I think we got probably 20 in the back. Yeah,
they wasn't as good as the ones that I put out regular. But you know,
when I first started I was kind of shy and I'm like, oh, I'm southern.
You know, I look how many times you have to say,
what the fuck did you just say back? But you're not shy. I was Kinda a,
that's the last word I would ever use for you fight. But I'm kind of shy Joe.
I mean, you know, cause I'm country and people are like the book the Twos,
I I d I actually talked about you. Oh my first one.
So when I first did your podcast,
it was a story out that Joe Rogan has a bad ass and he choked out on mountain
line. And I was like,
I don't want to go talk to no white man and talk about a fucking mountain line.
That's a made up story. I don't know.
But I didn't know at first and I was so scared.
Joe and I gives a mountain lion killer. Like I was out there choking nine.
I'm used to black people doing dry by way.
I used to wipe him to choking on a mountain lot.
So I'm trying to figure out how to fucking get up on a mountain lion
huddle face nick up on a mountain lion from behind and took the shit out of him.
He gotta be strong as fuck.
So I kept digging and I realized the store wasn't Roger. Oh,
I didn't want to talk to no white dude to choke down Tony.
You know, I'll see you in that big old weight is shit. That big old horse.
It was killed that fucking mountain lot.
It took a while for me to realize that it took about two,
about a month before I realized this store was [inaudible] sister didn't think
my own sister thought it was real. Really texted me. She goes,
you really choke out him out. Fuck is wrong with you.
You are bad as you. I mean only you can sneak up on a mountain lion.
[inaudible] I don't think so.
I run with a knife when I run, I,
I carry a knife with me just in case cause there's mountain lions in my
community. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
They've seen him and I run with my dog and Mountain Lion tries to Jack me or my
dog. I want to have something on me.
So you, you heavy jacket, now you go stabbing. Fuck yeah.
You know I was just telling the story about my, you know, I'm from the south,
right? So back in the day and no get offended people. But you know,
dog fighting is big in itself. So we didn't fight like no dangerous shit.
We just put some nanoliters on the ground who have a dog get the best they went.
And now late when my dog was named pop pop now or later.
You mean like candy now and laters the candy. Yeah. Candy. So yeah,
we'll have the dogs fight over candy. Yeah it will.
We shared a memento used to split the cane or whatever.
It's all good. Some kid, if it wins or black dogs just eat anything,
make them color green pig feet, whatever. Black Book.
Black people didn't buy dog food. So we will, we will.
Me and my dog will fight a lot. But if you got the best of my daughter,
I would jump in and whip your dog and you wasn't that going with my old lad
German shepherd.
And then I'll be calling and be talking about I'm abused the dog cause all the,
oh no fucking dolls. I got four crack babies and I don't have an animal.
This was back in the day and I was a little girl, but that's what we used to do.
It is a
thing in the south period. I knew a guy who had 30 pit bulls in his backyard.
He had these, uh, boxes like that.
He had the dogs live in these little dog houses and they were chained to a post
and they were in his yard and I didn't see it.
My friend was telling me about it, but I knew the guy and yeah, he lived down.
I lived in Kentucky. Yeah, we lived in Kentucky and um,
they fought dogs. Well, we only did it with just kids.
We only welcome, well, who have a dog get the best of who have a dog.
That's the one now. Right? So if I thought,
but we're about to get go down on his back.
I would jump in and put your dog in a choke hold cause I like wrestling.
I will fix it. Fuck yeah, I will fucking photo shit out of your dog.
I was not losing them. Now Lady Joe, we didn't eat a lot.
I can lose my only meal that day. Your only meal was an hour later.
Some days it may pop up. Was that on the side while be like we whipped his head,
it will pop up and we'll split the now later. Wow.
There's a lot of people right now listen, like is this lady for real?
And I can assure you, assure them that you are. I'm for real.
Y'All got a crazy fucking life. You know?
I mean there's so many people that are insulated from the kind of life that
you've had. They don't know anybody like you, you know?
So I'm realizing that Chris, my producer, I scared the shit out and he's like,
while you're yelling at me, I'm like, Chris, I'm not yelling. You know,
when a black woman and yellow, when she going to twist and hug,
they taken off well wig and I'm bucketing her bra. I'm yelling,
I'm just talking my voice. I have a deep voice in this. It carries. But I,
you know, it was crazy cause like I said,
he's a little white kid from Indianapolis. And, uh,
so I'm talking to on a podcast and I'm teaching them about Black Pussy incense.
You ever heard of that? Black Pussy incense? Yeah.
You know that you burned the black people used to buy it in the house.
I know about incense, but if nobody called Pussy, he slow me down.
It wasn't real. So we put out the podcast, everybody's like,
my mama say black pussy. It was the best [inaudible] Joe. Oh, okay.
You look like, what did it smell like? I like incense. Yeah, I know the name of,
and I told Joe, I told him about it. He's like, what are you talking about?
I'm like, I'm telling you, Blake was Izzy.
Everybody lives in the art Keller in burnt black plus the instance on a Saturday
morning cleaning house. Everybody listened to our Kelly and burnt black poses.
Holy Shit. Geez. So every weekend,
every week I'm teaching them something that he has never heard of.
What do you think about all this art, Kelly Shit.
Um, I think you did it Joe. I mean, but then people just look,
if people just looked away, you know it, it, I tell a beat on stage,
I say something about a big dig man, big Dick, black man, they can't read.
They puts it down. They
can't really put it down.
My first kid couldn't read if we went, ain't got no side teeth and they carry,
they got the best sex cause they practice all the time.
Black males who can't read, don't,
don't have safe like black men who got a nine to five who can read the sex is
totally different because they're not tired because they print this out at doing
practice on women. But you got my husband got to go to work, Joey.
He got tired of me flipping me over, slapped me across the head.
Oh my God.
[inaudible] when you got a brother that can't read and don't work the best six,
now he ain't gonna go to work.
But you gonna Watch the young and the wrestling and housewives of Atlanta.
But when you know, when you get back that that dig is laying on that pillow,
are you?
She looks good. I know Whitney used to wade through everybody
[inaudible] and you know you had to work even harder because you had more money
than him, right? Yeah, that's true.
So they had a meme they put up on the Instagram the other day of how every dude
whose girlfriend is paying for everything stands and it's like a guy standing
with his arm deep around the girl like deep around holding onto her while
they're waiting in line for things. Baby in public, always baby holding a hand.
You can't get my hold and hold my hand. You know,
why can't you pay the mortgage? I call home.
Yes. I say I love you. Say thank you. I'm in the bay. I was on the phone,
my friend one day motto. So I say listen to my husband, my husband,
funny as fuck. So I say, Hey, I said a baby. You want some pussy?
He say not at all.
No.
My first, I didn't say not at all. And I think that's what he's knowing already.
Oh yeah. That type of relationship as if, Hey,
I'm gonna need you to fuck me on 14 cause I think I'm out of the lane.
I need to get some stuff out my chance.
He'd say not at all. Joe, we bought a sleep number bed and he's like,
cause his knee was myth alum body sleep number bed.
I'm gonna put it out every night. I'm like fuck yeah.
So I had just got a deal with Fox for my TV show so I'll walk in now.
I walk in the damn mom sleep number like a real negro when they get some money.
Give me the best fucking batch you won't cause I'm more fuck every night.
There's so meal 30,000 now sleep number bed.
Well I should have no you weren't going to do shit cause he was insistent on
getting the metro that split down the middle. You know the two matches separate.
That's just split down the middle and out there time I want,
I'll say I've got 10 by eight you want to come to American gets was it?
We got the harder button side.
Hey no worries. I fucking want to own a mattress to cell phone out.
Come over here and then net. We don't gave up.
We just fucking in the middle and by the time we get through it and fucking
metro zone fell out the vehicle. We in the middle at a whole lap
and everyone's time just chips and shit. Just
don't remote. My Wig, everything.
I get my TV show home me a magic. Pull those back. The fucking gap.
Yeah. I didn't like that sleep number, but I tried the thing.
I was too confusing. I didn't like it. Oh, he loves the Joe.
Every time I come home he got his feet in the air like he had a gynecologist
visits. He's one of those. He thought, I'm like,
this measure is only good for heating your balls or we could've gotten to a blow
dry your balls up. They sell mattresses now.
That cool you Marc system was, yeah.
I'm want to get one that seems awesome. Yeah,
system was just telling me about that. I'm going through menopause.
I might need to get that through. I'll be heating up Joe and he, oh my tea.
I'm like,
I'm having a hot flash now and I don't want to drop my titties on your table,
but boy I see in here. I don't feel it. Joe,
when you get to turn the AC AC case, stop no high. She's like Fab, five minutes.
I'm heating up now, but yeah, it goes away. What does that cause by?
I don't know. You got to ask Mary. I don't know what Mary did in the beginning.
It was Mary with Jesus. No mayor with Jesus. When did Jesus Mama only the Bible.
What do you mean Mary? Mary, but who do you mean when you're saying marriage?
No, I'm sorry. I'm talking about eve and then who stopped?
Who started to hear you? I'm sorry. I get that. Oh Damn Bitch.
She fucked everything up. Yeah, that talking snake. Yeah, that talk is Nate.
I mean I'm cramps ain't no joke and now I'm having a hot flash.
I'm because this bitch better after God.
Can you get me an opportunity by the apple? I won't bite the Apple.
Take the half.
I'd be on a plane with TD heat up and wipe me and next to him.
You don't understand why I got my titty and my lap
faring yourself off? Yes, yes. Yeah.
It comes and goes in like last five minutes and then the a few minutes and then
we'll go back to mom. Like I'm cooling down now.
So like out of nowhere you just get hot.
Yeah and they hit you in different places. Like Mas is good.
Between my titties on my neck, some people's is up under day arms.
You know in a spot like one smile hit me right here. My titties,
my titties heat up. Like if you touch them that about 95 degrees,
don't touch them because you married,
but I'm just saying I don't want you burn your fingers. There it goes.
More than two thirds of North American women who are headed into menopause have
hot flashes.
They also affect women who start menopause after chemotherapy or surgery to move
them over. It doesn't say anything on why it's North American.
That's what I was wondering. It says, what is a hot flash?
It's a sudden feeling of heat. Sometimes a red flush face and sweating.
We don't know exactly what causes them,
but the may related to changes in circulation.
I guarantee you if they happen to men, they'd know exactly what caused them. Oh,
they'll fix that shit. They figured it out. Oh yeah.
They'll fix that junk if they can fix a soft penis. Yeah,
they'll fix the mandate. But we can't do nothing with our body.
Not Fixing soft dicks and everything else to be solved. No,
I don't think that would work.
Is there any six that you can't say stop fixing soft?
You'd have to like unlearn that. I'd have to unlearn Viagara look,
just let the man Dick do what it do. When it dilated that,
then that's the point where the lady need to know what you need to put some
cocoa butter up on the hippest lot across it that
I don't think that's going to help either. When is always override, I guess.
Yeah. Yeah. People,
I think that they would be happy when it's over like good. Finally,
women are happy when they peers don't come on. Well,
why can't man be happy when a penis don't work?
Cause for men like your Dick not working as a sign of you don't,
you're not a man anymore. Yeah, for sure. Ooh. Hey,
you feel like you're not a man anymore? Oh really? Yeah.
So I don't feel like I'm not a woman. I'm older. My parents stopped.
We'd be happy. Yeah. But it's different.
If you're pussy dried up and became useless, like sealed up
like nothing. You know, like maybe you meet a man,
maybe you and your husband get divorced. You met a man, he's beautiful.
Can read.
So he's got good Dick and don't put it in a mess down there.
Oh yeah, no, I'm black. He'd grow real thick.
So it's always a mess down.
I call it nappy grit. Well I got a Jackson five and fro.
I mean for some women it matters. But I guess, cause I started really early,
I don't want no dick. I want health care. Oh No.
D you ain't gotta do that to me. Just take you on a trip. I put for men though,
it's like a sign of weakness. It's a weakness. Then. Yeah,
you don't feel like a man anymore. If you love that person, I think you ready.
Are you willing to deal with the softness? Yeah.
Especially if you don't want any dirt. Yeah.
You would want Dick and his Duke ice cream sticks around it.
Oh, like a brace with someone. A broken leg.
You break your leg in the forest and they have to fucking strap it to some twigs
. What else would they was doing before [inaudible] came along?
I don't know what they were doing. Theresa do it too. Oh, that's what,
that's why they kill rhinos. You know Rhino Horn,
they think rhino horn gets your dick hard. It doesn't do shit. Do you eat it?
I guess they make a tea out of it. Oh really? It doesn't even work.
But guys been taken Rhino Horn forever to try to get their dick hard and so much
so that now that it's forbidden and it's expensive because it's forbidden.
It's like a sign of luxury. Like you're drinking rhino horn t it's a big thing.
And apparently some Asian countries,
like with like wealthy people and we have decent Asian, they don't,
I mean I heard they was small. You heard,
well I have a girlfriend, six Asian babies. Right. But she don't have
any scratch marks. Well, and I was just telling babies, you know,
most women get stretch marks. Right. But I don't think that has to do with Dick.
But I'm saying Asian means make small babies,
so. Hmm. I'm just assuming. Well, would've been, it's like go,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
I missed the basketball player was the the the giant dude. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
yeah. What about that guy? Oh, and if he has a normal size, he too tall.
He ain't got no Dickies to too,
I guarantee you he pissed on the top of his pants.
It's so, it's a way a man Bron James is tall too. He got a lot of Dick.
I saw that nick on TV that day. I bet. Oh my God. When he went to go scratch,
I was like, I'm not into young Dick like that. But that was nice. And I
got, I'll tell you somebody else. You've got a nice,
oh Nikki Minaj is ex boyfriend safari. Yeah. He broke the animate, waited.
He broke down and got, he had a curve.
Any Joe fucking lip you can ask?
It could probably live a weight in his fucking weight room right here. Wow.
It was so big. He couldn't even fit on an iPhone. It was only iPad action.
I was sending it to everybody. Bitch, look, you blessed today. You blessed.
Oh my God. And he made a little five minute video.
That thing was swinging like the American flag on top of a building.
It was nice.
That's a thing like you either have a big Dick or you do not.
There's nothing you can do about it. Like there's operations at dudes get this.
Somebody just died from that. Yeah. Billionaire diamond seller.
A guy who was a thing. It was in Europe somewhere in Europe,
some billionaire diamond trading Dafoe. I'm a Dick Implant.
While they were doing the operation and when they put him under due to
complications of anesthesia, he died. He was like 65 years old too.
I mean when you're 65, wouldn't you think you're like, good luck.
Have I ever had this small thing all my life?
I'm a diamond dealer who's not going to turn this down.
Probably have some young little floozies with and she's just as a few.
It was dick was a little bit bigger. Maybe I'd be happy.
Bitch. You going to be happy in the way your diamond dealer? Maybe not.
Maybe there's other diamonds.
Dealers always want to give her a bigger dick. You know,
it depends on how hot the girls, you know some, some girls get a lot of offers.
I get no offers. What's up Jamie? Sorry we looked this up but it's that,
I remember that thing. They slide in there. That piece of plastic.
Oh that's right. It's the implant. Uh, it's like a mesh.
They is a website for it. Penn. Yeah. Penn Numa. Wow. Look at this shit.
Look they, they take like a look at that. It's like a webbing. Yeah.
Put the glasses.
I said, man, I'm a grown ass man. The
large extra large and extra, extra large.
Who the fuck is going to go with large? Just have large the fuck out of here.
You're going to get put under and they're going to stick a rod in your Dick.
Get that extension. It's a it a pair. Well,
let's play the video for you guys to see. Not The new muscle. Yeah,
the people online are not going to believe this. But see, look at that.
That's a dick. That's, that's a regular deck.
Now what they do is they do see if you have a dick like that, Jesus Christ,
don't get it cut. Just deal with it. Just deal with it. But some people,
there's never enough. You know, like some people want kinds of crazy shit.
So they take this [inaudible] they put a slice above the deck,
watch whoopsies like a c section out.
Exactly. The open that shit up. Like a change purse.
And then they slide this tube and Nagy.
Yeah. And then the
Kapow.
So that's what that dude got. He didn't make it out of house. Bill. No,
he's dead now. He's dead. A big box of diamonds at home. No, he did.
What a big Dick. I did.
They got to the big dick part so it makes you Dick Fatter and longer and the
procedure takes approximately 45 minutes.
Sexual activity can typically be resumed in four to six weeks.
Patients are ambulatory the next day. Oh my God.
Ambulatory and was it say returned to routine daily activities in two to three
days? Patients do not experience any issues with urination after the procedure.
Possible risks, complications,
alternatives and benefits will be discussed by the surgeon prior to the
procedure. Oh and you could fucking die. Wow. Yeah, man.
Anytime you get put under, I mean that's is not how Connie's mom died.
Didn't she die from plastic surgery? I think she was getting a stomach, Don.
I think a lot of that is just,
I want my stone done once I finish losing weight, don't do it.
I want my titties lifted. You don't know my titties.
Getting put under is what I worry about. Well, Shit.
I mean I want my titties lifted.
I understand this hall when you got big titties and they all in your lap and
shit. When your bro come off.
Do you want your wife to walk out the shower with her?
TD looked like they'd been in a dry bar. I feel you.
I understand what you're saying. Yeah. So I want my titties lifted.
I want my just my stomach done. I'm wanting you to stay alive in this pattern.
I'm gonna stay alive. I love you. I love you too. I'm going to get me a verge.
Juven nation too. Don't do it. Don't do it. Don't get a tightened up.
I thought he said you don't even want anymore Dick White hit the time.
Dawn through Penn and London's like pamphlets.
Oh my God. Rejuvenation. Fix that. I don't know, but I got to leak that upon.
We can't fix
what's happening there. Just coffee. Huh? Chew. I'm wearing.
He's my friend Y'all. That's the only reason I could tell him.
Let me pissing on my cell. That's all right. I mean, I don't want no,
I don't want no Kim Kadash and them don't want to knows and I,
I'm okay with my black nose. Beautiful. Thank you. Oh, I'm a teach.
Pull it back. But I would like Joe.
I would like to get my stomach done so I can see my vagina.
It's been a long time. We've been disconnected for a long time.
Have you ever gone on a yeah. Didn't like it is the way he said it
was said you lost a hundred pounds and it just stopped. So I caught a dog,
but it's like it stopped and he was like, oh, you got to go to the gym.
I'm like, no. So you lost a hundred pounds, just dieting. No.
I would have weight loss surgery 10 years ago. And that was real juicy.
I was almost 400 pounds. So you had the stomach staple thing?
Yeah, my stomach could. Yeah, it was. It was. It was easy as hell. Really?
Yeah. All I was, I was almost ready at four. Wow. And I lost like,
you lost a hundred pounds and then they told you to go to the gym and you're
like, fuck you. Well, I'm just so busy. I, there's no fucking excuse. I mean,
I was a trainer. That could be another podcast. You complaining at the gym.
That shit would be hilarious. I would be complaining.
That would be hilarious or something crazy. My kids are fed cause you lived.
The parents is fat. The key is a fat. My son was 410 pounds.
Joe and I live in this white neighborhood and they couldn't get no pussy and
literally went on a diet joke.
When I tell you this boy is 220 pounds and every night when we go to bed,
he'd go in the Pantry, throw away the junk, and I said, you got one more time.
Throw away my motherfucking food. He's like, y'all can eat that.
He read everything. He just go to the gym. He was fat as fuck. That's amazing.
Kiddies, his titties gone. His stomach flat air. The fruit day. What does he do?
What kind of exercise? I don't know. I can call him his name. June bug.
June bug. Yeah. Not his real name. He's, that's his nickname. Yeah. Nickname.
Gym Addict. He's it fucking gym ad and he's beautiful. He told, he's like,
I'm gonna make this whole family lose weight. I said, not today bitch.
Chill ass. Why don't you do a podcast
and Momma at the gym? Oh God, funny.
A video of you at the gym would be just you complaining and talking shit or
somebody gets you to work out. God Damn hilarious. Duma,
we're going to do a podcast, but he gonna try to kill me, Joe.
But if you just listened to him and did it and did a video,
I guarantee you that we get a shitload of views. Okay,
well me and Junebug do my weekends. You're going to help them. Well,
actually I'm getting ready to move to La for the pilot of my show.
You're gonna move here. I'm gonna move here for a little bit. For how long? Uh,
well we gonna shoot the pilot. So if the poly get picked up at Hulu,
so I be here doing the shooting and then I'm gonna go back home.
I can't take all these nice Teddy's run around,
so I'm gonna Bring Junebug out with me
to start filming video. You all, it seemed like he had big titties. Like mines.
They're gone. Beautiful. I love it. You'll love stories like that.
And now he just did it. I know what it was. He couldn't get laid.
Well that'll be a motivator. Yeah. And I asked him, I said, son, be on him.
Cause he told me, he said Momma, cause I mean I'm doing a little bit now,
probably lost like 15 pounds since I've been dealing with jumbo. He say, Mama,
when you lose weight, when you started to lose weight,
he just texts me when he said, dude, come on your period. What are you main?
I'm your
fucking Momma. He's like,
I want to be in the room. When these conversations are happening, said,
why are you asking you to ace it? Because when I help you lose weight,
your parents won't come back. I said,
why fucking period is not going to come with your son a doctor? I don't know.
He just read all the time. Joe,
I lost like 12 pounds and my peer came out. I was like, Bill. He was like,
I know Momma, you stopped up from all the fat. I said, I don't think it worked.
Like she
stopped. Oh
you told me I'm stopped up Joe. But my cycle came on. I'm like,
what the fuck you do to be my what? The more I work with the moe, you go flow.
So He's right. That's what's crazy. Yeah.
He just reads a lot about fitness and health. He's, I'm telling you Joe,
how old is he? He's 19 and what is he doing? He works, he works at enterprise.
He, he should get together with you.
Fuck enterprise two together working out, making youtube videos.
That would be huge. Yeah. Especially if I can get out on like him. He's like,
mom, I'm going to get you in shape. And my daughter is on a plus size too.
He's like, I'm whipping all y'all ass all because he just, he just,
he just popped up and said I'm sick of being fat. That's awesome.
He said he was sick of being fat. My baby, if you go to my Instagram,
he's on the hill and he's even, he's two 20 now. I'm like jumbo stop.
He's like no. Wow. I mean he got a cheers Joe stomach flat.
He looks good. And I asked him, I said, son did you did get bigger?
Cause I remember being really small.
He's like, it's better mom. It's bad. When you're fat,
your Dick gets smaller. Hey,
your naval become your Dick when you real fat Joe. Oh my God,
you should do that. Like, look, I talked you into doing a podcast.
I'm going to talk you into doing this. You have to, okay, June bug.
I know you're going to see this moon bug please. You and your mom at the gym.
It'd be gigantic. I'll help you. I'll promote it.
I'll put it up on Twitter and Instagram. Please do this.
So Eagle Kiyomi you go,
I got to go in there with a depend on if he gets you in crazy shape.
Imagine if you get to like bikini shape. Seriously,
I ain't been like that since the third grade.
I need a bikini shape. I'm telling you Joe, he could do that though.
He does that. Joe,
you don't know how happy I would be if I could just look straight down and see
shit. A lot of times the food that you crave is the food that you eat,
so if you eat food that's not healthy for it.
That's what you're craving all the time. Your stomach gets used to it.
The what they call your gut biome. Stomach bacteria wants sugar,
bread and pasta. As soon as you start eating healthy food,
your body starts craving healthy food. Your body will start craving salads and
lean meat and chicken and fish too. I don't know what else he started.
We don't drink water, but I do now. He makes me drink.
Well he literally call me Mama cause I can do one liter a day.
I'm up to one liter. That's the NOCCA. What do you drink besides water? Oh,
I drink coffee in the morning and not that, that normal coffee.
I have to have one cup. Coffee is fine. Yeah, I do. I do put sugar and cream in.
I got full Craig. Maybe I need something to call my down.
So I told my son I can't give up my car for right now.
So I drink coffee only in the morning and then I drink what hour day?
I work on a little water and he literally go to the House and tell us what we
can and can't eat,
which is I be want to punch him in the face but I am losing a few panels with
him. Like you know I got an f,
I got the back whim arms like grandmama and he's like, mom,
I'm going to get all of that off with you. Cause he were here.
Pheromones two and big titties.
I mean he lost all of it and I'm so proud of it. You could do it too.
Yeah cause I was told him, I said,
look you 19 you're on the insurance at 26 they will give you weight loss
surgery. I ain't like, I don't want that. That's the song.
Go get the weight loss or didn't I get your t taken off and your stomach.
Totally. He's like, mom, that don't sound like no manly thing
because I hate it.
Play it out.
I was going to get his Tommy Toe and his titties cut off and I'm going to get
them weight loss surgeon. I'm a fat daughter. She fat and I said,
I'm going to get your Tommy Toe. I'm going to get your stomach cut.
And then [inaudible] Una is cause she had no A's. So,
and then I told my husband he don't have no A's. I was going to buy him my age.
Jesus Christ in bite. Everybody asks,
you know what? You know people getting cancer from that as is. Yeah.
When I take the fat from, you know, not only they take the fat,
they get a lot of fat. They getting cancer from the implants. What?
Titties ass implants. Oh, I ain't gonna do no ask. They play got bigger.
You do you, there's no issue. But some people who get ass implants,
they're starting to get cancer. Oh, real ass implants are only a few years old.
Uh, you know what? I don't understand. I'm from the inner state of Atlanta.
When we was coming up, Joe,
if you want it titties and A's and they had this thing going around and I did a
podcast on it. I said, we didn't people,
black people didn't know where place the surgery work.
So the deal was you take that government butter and you rub it on your tds and
your eggs and they said it'll make it grow. What? Yeah, I'm not allowed to you.
That's what we used to do back in the day. What's up?
Look at me. Yeah, but I'm looking, look at me. Don't think it's from the butter.
Uh, ever. Ever Bet. I know robot on there.
You don't know that government [inaudible] on. I want a job.
They sent to the ghetto to kill everybody. Joe,
I've got to tell you these stories.
So once I was in the tub and Monday was like,
just put the bottle on your TDA is we put the bottle on my Mama.
We cause she's like, no, you bitches. They got my blood on y'all. You
know that shit got to last me 28 mode day. She took this to Jakarta. She here.
Doesn't that motherfucker stuck in that bottle? She gave us one on one. Who She,
I sprayed my shit off. You bitches. We're not scraping her. Brought all of us.
She put that shit back in the frigerator. She beat the shit out.
She scraped the butter off your tits and put it back in the fridge.
We'll pull. We can waste on that good bottle, Joe. God, that is hilarious.
She beat the shit out of those planning.
Her butter magic butter really did that.
All you had to do to get big tits and a big ass just [inaudible].
This is the fourth grade, so that's when I didn't like it.
You just have good genetics now Joe. My Mama didn't have no titties. Yeah,
but sometimes it doesn't get your mom, but it goes to, you know,
I'm trying to kill the government. Don't do that. Education and shit.
Joe, go break it all the way down for the lady. Let him try to bottle my phone.
They try to pause it. Okay,
so go out and get you some good old government butter.
They won't mail and just sat on it like a,
like a fucking a bird trying to hit your aide. Just sit. All right. Yeah,
I do rub it all your booty and stuff like and hopefully it'll make your booties
and titties grow and run for it. Didn't work. Imagine if that work.
There's a lot of questions on you,
Yahoo. People asking that does [inaudible] make your butt bigger?
And then I found a product on Amazon called butt butter
cream for smoother, fuller, and firmer skin. I don't know if that's what I have.
Yeah, natural button enhanced cream for women and men.
Plump booty enhancer lotion but firming and tightening cream.
Sexy. But was it, hold on. Sorry. It was sexy. But lifter cream button.
Larger cream. This is horse shit. Most likely it's got four stars.
It's a bunch of people that are assholes that work for the company.
They're reviewing it 364 customer reviews. Hold on, click.
They're
good. One or bad one. The good ones. Adding to my flat booty,
my family and I and my family.
I inherited flat Butt Syndrome. It's embarrassing.
It's embarrassing.
Have your butt hurt because you have no padding when you sit and have no pants
fall. Have your pants fall because there's nothing in the back to hold them up.
After week I def notice something extra in the back. I'll keep using.
That's the people that you want to buy your butt cream cause they're morons.
That's like people that give money to preachers that flying private jet.
Yeah. I think that's crazy. That don't work. But I,
I'm telling you government butter work, Joe, I'm telling you,
do this. Who would have known it works faster on your breasts and on your butt,
but it's work more. This is not real at me.
I'm a 40
Casey. She no
glasses on. So funny. I'm telling you God. But listen, these fucking,
the people that are writing these reviews,
not only does it works, that's it works. Not only does it works,
it increased my breast size.
They probably should change the name to breast and button, hand spent butter.
I know it for the, but I know it for the butt. So I figured, let me see,
will it do anything for my breast since it's in quotes, all natural.
So I did. So within a week,
my breast was fuller. Last time I seen them,
this size was right before it was time to press feed and my baby is now nine
years old.
Oh. So I imagine what we was doing in the ghetto.
I'm telling you at thick as butter, I'm 10 does work it out.
The Black Watch.
I made it people who knows what I'm talking about from the South St Joe.
We did that and it worked. I assume I grew tin isn't,
but we should have done it on one titty. Did it just to see.
No, John wanted to know to be here.
I know one way to find out what actually works. One cheek, one tick.
You bounce it out left cheek, right?
Well I'm going to find that but butter and rub it on my crack baby.
One of her titties and see if they grow in their head.
Just don't even tell him what you're doing. Just put it on one titty. Okay.
I'm gonna have to get her to do it. I don't think I'll feel appropriate.
How old is she now? She's nine. It's too late. No, no, she's a,
they're like four. You can do it. You have a five year. I can test it,
but she already got a big ass booty. Oh yeah.
Then when I'm going come and get some of that and see if it work.
My husband would kill me. I was, I don't know if it's true,
but I don't think it is. It doesn't make sense. But then again,
I'm not a scientist.
I'm telling you it's like that peanut butter that they used to send to the
ghetto to choke negroes out.
Well I love you too.
What did they do
that they used to send to the gut?
The government used to give black people peanut butter that show come out
because they didn't want to talk about peanut butter. You had to heat it.
You want your microwave to heat it on the stove. Like you buy the cookers,
scrambled eggs for the thing now, so you just spread it on the sandwich. Really.
Then they find later on they were going to kill us. It was like a,
it was thick as fuck. It came in a cane. The Goldman peanut butter.
Go Google it. It was some dude on Instagram who was in school,
some kid in school and were
they, you know,
they feed them cheese sandwiches for lunch and he was lighting the cheese
sandwich. He was like, look at this cheese, look at this shit.
And he's lighting. He's got a lighter too. It would not melt.
It was just turning black. It was just getting black from the smoke,
from the lighter. It was not melting. It wasn't,
what the fuck kind of cheese is this?
Yeah. And it wasn't real cheese.
There's this parts of America that the government ignores, right? Yeah.
Me. Yeah.
You got through who made it through the net? Yeah.
But then they only come to you when they, when they need to vote,
they only come to the like black pastor. They like black pastors, you know?
That's why I don't go to church. I tell them all the time, I tied at churches.
Chicken, you get more for your money. Churches, chickens better.
$2 Tuesday, get your two piece chicken in a biscuit. What you're talking about
the lead up Popeye's. A load on Tuesday and go to churches. Yeah,
but did they have the spicy spices now? Yeah. Yeah.
That's the thing. I'm like, I'm not getting over pastor my money.
Good for you and ride not there. I mean, Hey, the Bob is free.
Then every hotel just did abide by the hotel like everybody else used to.
I'm not going to get you my mind.
Then you out here by buying jets and shit and I'm struggling.
Then you fucking holes in church. Rainy share sharing holes in church.
Nomo they're fucking nose in church. Oh yeah, they beat some. Fuck Yo.
I don't know. I don't go to church.
Go to church with no underwhelm to get the pastor. Oh fuck the first lady.
They don't can them back. The first lady goes,
wear no underwear in church to lure the pastor. Really? You ain't much.
The pastors is sexy as fuck.
Remember back in the day when you might not remember cause you white,
but Megan and
begging and date a pastor was ugly. Oh the possible ugly. Like TD Jakes.
They was on fuckable but now they all sexy.
Then they all sexy me. Everybody want to fuck the pal seeker.
That's what they said they meant when they made Catholic church preachers become
celibate.
One of the reasons why the man would come celebrate is because the Catholic
preachers were banging all the ladies there.
They were like rock stars because they were the ones who are the word of God.
And this was before anyone could read the Bible because it was all in Latin.
So they didn't know how to read Latin.
So they relied on these priests to read it. Look at Joe Austin.
He's fuckable. Oh yeah. I haven't known him at this little kid. Yeah.
Do you think he got some getting him song
and not in Jesus' name?
No ones sexy Georgia state shit.
I don't even do white me Lauer. Do Joe Esteem in the pool pit.
Do you think he gets him? He got a wave. Yeah, but other than her,
he got some on the side. Bitch
fucking with me. Hey.
And I let him call me that too. Wow. Yeah. You pay the bill. Look at him.
Look at him. He killed any ea aged at all.
Look at that for here to hell. He's 60 he walked down
faithy I bet he does have a six pack, right? Yeah.
He got a six pack and problems and his wife in the upper right corner.
Go back 56 lose good for 56 let's go though.
Is that his wife? She's hot. Yeah. She hasn't played with their call.
Let's just say this. His wife Kapow. Yeah, he could take that.
Joel joy is good luck. I've got a guy named marina [inaudible].
She's got a date. They are the new drug though. They're the new pimps.
Pimps had holes and they go on a cone and slept.
They hold and get their money or the church is like that now. That's all it is.
He does it in Vegas at the same arena where the UFC plays.
I thought he was in Dallas. He goes all over the place.
He goes on the road sometimes they go on the road and he said he's in Houston or
Dallas somewhere in Texas. Houston does that,
but he also does like giant arenas on the road. I'm like, he does.
He does the t mobile center, whether UFC place, look at that size,
that place now you can keep dad.
How many of those pictures in the audience have no underwear on?
Probably about 60%
great. He's
going to church when they started charging for meals. I don't fucking know.
Oh my God. Yeah. You Ain't noticed that.
I didn't know that they were banging on the front row.
Smell like an oyster bar. Yeah. It's smell like
they try, hey, that's how you have a baby by a man. Like Yo, oh Steve,
you pay the child spoke. Oh, you don't want, imagine if you're,
if you're the type of person that wants that much money, right?
You want that much money. You want private jets, you want big houses,
you're to want some extra pussy. Hey,
go get tired of paying the same plastic face. White woman. She looked good.
Yeah. This guy get tired. I'm like, he wants somebody like me with the t.
Did they move on the inside and move on the inside? Yeah. You know,
I got the real t. There's so much shit go all over the place. Oh, and Herzer.
Yeah. They just from, they just one position up straight.
That's weird that people like that. They're like, I'm a hard,
and I got them t you gotta pick up and dull style slot.
No does cause everything in my bra.
I like how gross you out.
You're going to be at home like Nah, this bitch Yo,
I'm telling you sometimes just the other podcasts we've done with,
I just stopped in the middle of the dangle. What the fuck?
Yes. Some of this shit. Well mostly about the tragedies.
Mostly about your childhood. It's funny now Joe. It's just that I took out. I,
you know, I, I say on stage, I say it, um, ah, when you, when you,
when you can laugh at what you've been through, then you got control of it.
Only the reason why I can laugh about being shot and I even my husband hate this
bit. I do. I do
a bit about, uh, my first kid's father, you know, giving me crabs,
gunnery in fleas,
fleas. She gave me a combo with no toy
fucking sleaze. I mean, people get crabs, I get it.
But when someone gives you flees, like what the fuck?
But back in those days the health department would come and pick you up and say,
Hey, you put c on five, we need to put it out. They pick you up, pick you up.
And he beat him, gave somebody else crap.
I'm going gonna run Fleece on some bitch or report everybody. He was missing.
We and I was always on the list. Oh Geez. I was like,
how can you tell people they,
I think it's funny that they used to come get me and me and the health
department man had a relationship. Now we want sleeping together. He just say,
Hey, you post, it was on the list again.
Like how can you tell people that? I also think it's fucking hilarious.
I don't have a STD. When I was young, you know,
it was simple shit. Gunnery, you got to shout in. Yeas.
And I remember that they came one time, Joe and um,
they knocked on the door and I said, oh my God, you here.
I thought you was gonna let me brought up. He's like, you put someone in.
Listen, I'm here to put it out. So,
so Mike
[inaudible] your pussies on the list pretty much. Call it your pussy.
He said [inaudible] report it.
So my kid's father was there. I was like, let's go together and get cured.
He's all, I don't want to go. Somebody might see me. So this is what he told me.
Say Look, it was going to run when you have gone to,
you need to get a shot or you take pills for seven days. So he said, look,
go to the health department but don't get the shot.
Get the pills so we can split them. So I'm so stupid.
I come back and split the seven day pills with them and we still both got half.
Oh my God, we didn't take the medication all the way. So, oh my God,
that's stupid.
I was like crazy while you tell people this shit and everybody always think he
gave me gun and shot me and beat me like can you please tell the people I didn't
do this shit to you?
How does he deal with you having this act like when you go on stage and talk
about all this shit, how does he handle it? Does he cover his ears? He,
he never, he only seen me once. What? He won't come see me, Joe, come on.
He wouldn't, he came to see me with cat Williams,
asked him when I was opening up for Kat Williams and uh,
but that's the only time. But he's, he's gotta know. Oh,
he didn't know funny as fuck. Like how did he not want to see that?
He don't want to see a Joe.
We'll tell him to come to the comedy store tonight cause you're gonna be there
for the 10 30 show. Hell yeah, he's, he's even Naplan.
He don't watch your fucking podcast and tell my daughter,
oh she was so fucking funny. But he's not gonna direct it to say to me,
he was so fucking funny. But he's my biggest cheerleader. I mean,
he's supportive. I mean, you know,
I've been doing this 17 you know how many times
I had to make that man credit card out to go and do it.
So you know. Well, he would not come see me. He's like, look, I live with you.
I hear that she ever debt,
but he gives me back like he's funny to me. Like I told you saying not today.
I want to it a day at at all. Yeah, not at all.
He's says some of the funniest shit. Oh, well he's a he, but you know,
he's only seen you do comedy once. The one time out of 17 years.
It's a good one though to open for cat Williams. He's still in touch with cat.
No, but I love care. Cain about a damn. He shared about care. We all,
my daddy died. Well my daddy died and I just got a job with cat Williams.
He walked in there. He was like, what are you doing? I said,
my daddy died like two days before. He called me on a tour and I said,
we trying to, I'm just trying to get this money together,
raising care wouldn't go to the bank, come at with a stack of money.
He gave me like four green to bare my dad and I was like you don't have to do
this. And I was like I work for, he's like look no go Barea daddy.
Cause before he did that Alba put my fucking dad in on potato sack and stick him
in the ground cause we had no money and I tried to do the fish fry in the black
community. I mean the white neighborhood,
they don't own them about no fucking face frown.
No Tuesday and cat wouldn't gave me the money to bury them. That's hot. Yeah.
Okay. Nobody tell me Shit about cat weed.
He's crazy. But he's funny as fuck. He's,
he's one of my favorites all time and he tell the fucking truth too.
If you go to go back to like the pimp chronicles is in his prime, that is,
those are some of the best specials ever. Yes.
He's a funny motherfucker and he's so original. Still original like that is him.
You know what I mean? Like his delivery, his style, everything.
I love him. Can't nobody tell me shit about no kit weed.
I'm going to cause a cat, William.
I was able to finish my basement after their tour.
He, uh, he gave me some, not gave me,
but he gave some great advice once about comedy.
One of the things he says don't eat before you go on stage. And I was like,
yeah, why would you, you don't eat before you fight.
Why did you eat before you go on stage?
What does it causes your body that your body when you eat has to break down that
food? So it's, it's using up energy,
like some of the energy that you would have to do stand up is now breaking down
that food in your body. That is what I'm about to fall asleep on stage. Yes.
Yes. Shit, I got to stop eating. Just don't eat right before you go on stage.
Does eat afterwards. Okay. Yeah, I mean I listen to him and I was like,
that makes so much sense.
And also he has a playlist of music that he plays right before he goes on stage.
Like sets it up like it just like puts him in the mood to go on stage.
Yeah, I do that too. I do that. I do that too. I like a lot of 'em.
Um, I, I wanna say out. Okay, but that ain't what I'm going for.
Hulu fucking rap. I let's Carly B oh, deload nasty thing.
That's what I would be if I had a body like that. Oh my God,
that girl got a tone, got a drag afloat. She might,
she that person in my head and I want to be, I listen to a lot of Kali B.
I like her. Maybe you can get that body.
Uh, maybe, maybe Junebug bug you in that gym.
Get on that elliptical machine. Come on June Bob,
we're gonna need you to help your mom out June bug and stop your mom from peeing
on a sale. Just, just change up the Diet. I'm working,
I sweat, and next time you see me near Sun, I'm going to look like you.
If you do that, did they go too hard? I tell you,
go to a different doctor. I'm like, but if you,
if you did that, I'm telling you,
if you did a video with your son and your son getting you to the gym and did
that regularly on, on Youtube, June bug and Miss Pat, just do that.
It would be hilarious. It'd be so funny. Cause I, I,
cause you know I got lucky is out. I want,
especially when they're making you do shit,
you don't want to do like working out like doing sit ups and shit and squats and
all that spread my legs did.
Ain't never been used at a waste since the eighties.
My butthole. Exactly. Yeah. Doing what we doing it. Do it,
do it. Definitely do it. So, so you do you bring like, um,
I bring like one of those um, um, uh, Mp3,
no Bluetooth speaker things with me. You know,
I have like one of those JPL extremes.
I bring that with me and I put it in the green room. Play music. Oh,
not usually. Listen to music on my, to my before performing. Yeah. No,
I listen to music, um, on my phone. Yeah, but you get yourself in a mood.
Do you, do you have a drink before you go on stage?
I don't drink alcohol at all. No, nothing. Oh, what about weed?
I don't do any weed. You don't know nothing. I grew up in that environment.
I understand. As I say, I just don't, I mean, you don't need it.
There was nothing for me. It makes me sleepy. And um,
my mom was an alcoholic and I used to always say,
I'm going to be nothing like this bitch is hell.
So mission accomplished. Yeah. So I don't, I don't do it at my,
my whole family drink and I just don't do it. Yeah. I don't, I don't smoke weed.
I don't, you know, I was just telling them earlier,
like jumbo tried to smoke weed one time and it was his white friends,
but they were so stupid. Joe, they didn't know how to roll the wheat.
So they got the, they got the um, the,
the copy of paper off the machine and rolled the weed in there. Oh God. Yeah.
And Tommy leading it is Burt and out a wheat fell in his chest and I beat the
dog shit out of jumbo. And I told them, oh,
I don't burn up grocery for you to create an appetite. You already fucking fat.
Oh my God. And I just told my kids when they was younger, I say, look,
I told my son I kill. I said, look,
I get food stamps and I don't get enough food stamps for your weed habit.
So we not gone do drugs, we're not going to join gangs.
We're not going to do drugs is awesome fucker. So we not gonna do it. So,
but Junebug is the only kid I ever had that really tried to dab into weed.
That's a weird way to do it though. Copy paper. Whoa, this was terrible for you.
They will go to the ghetto and buy the wheat out of it. Out of where I live it,
they would go over to the ghetto. So I was like, Jumoke how much you eat?
How much wheat you buy? 1.5 grams. What the
hell is dead? I don't know. And I called the police on him. I said,
what are you d I called the police on the shake him up, right. And I,
you know called the police. Yeah. But I said, hey,
we black so leave your guns in the car. So come over here and shake my son.
The police get over there. The police and Junebug son go to school together.
This motherfucker come on there and start crying. We love you June. But I said,
they call you with a fucking cry.
[inaudible] I was crying so that didn't help.
But eventually I think he gonna stop smoking now. He's going to stop or start.
I think he stopped. I ran off all his friends. I told him, I said, look, yo,
your white son just lost his only black friend.
I'm going to fuck your white baby up. Bring them back over here with the, we
didn't do more like everybody at my school say you a snitch. I said fuck them.
I whooped him white boy, his ass.
Cause I called, I called on a pair, so I called all the parents.
I said they'll be smoking weed and looking at some little white girl puts it on
the phone. I said, Juma, you bless you mama.
But his wife puts it floating on the phones. Oh look, a girl from the school.
Yes. Get in trouble for that. So I put the, I put the chrome cast,
the pitcher, and I called out of pants. Ooh, white baby puts this downward.
Yeah, you put it on the TV. Yeah, put it on there was pissed off at me. Look,
kick the bitches away from Junebug fucking Tim Grady Little Dick. It's real,
real small redneck trying to kill my baby.
Trying to get my baby locked up for some white person.
You don't fuck with white plus you ain't got no Vicky,
you ain't got enough sense. Oh my God.
So you had the parents come over and I had asked who white man puts the decision
. What the fuck did they say? I can't believe you did this,
but the fuck you mean it was on their phones. Y'all started looking at it.
They stormed up.
They wouldn't speak to me and know no county, no friends. Oh my God.
I said don't you ever in Your Life Valet? No.
Cause she gave to one of the football player.
He just passed it around everybody. Yeah. And I saw him,
I said Junebug thinking about it dude was your sister Gary on him?
He's like Mama [inaudible] ain't getting naked today d cause nobody see nothing.
Yeah,
that's just the stuff I went through where he's the only one that ever really
try me. Cause my other kids, you know I tell like I tell my crack baby, I say,
look, I'm gonna take y'all out in public but you got an option.
Do you want to get on mom or do you want the soccer mom?
And they don't like to get on mom cause you get on.
Mom would knock the shit out of them in public and I give them a option and we
get in public and white people always come to me like, oh my God,
your kids are so well disciplined. I said,
I told them I was going to fuck him up.
He say when you said they just look like what? I said,
you should fuck your kids up too. I tell him, I said, hey,
I said I will fuck you up. Don't play with me. I feed you.
When we was coming back from the Disney cruise,
they was all playing with those little things that separate,
you know when you're in line. So I told him like
three,
four times stop isn't the my grand baby and it was the full Craig baby so they
wouldn't stop Joe. I slept all of them at the same time.
[inaudible] white people are like, what the fuck? I said,
what you're looking at me for? You all saw him too.
I asked him to stop by full time. Don't play with me. You know my nerves bad.
I've been shot a couple of times.
Y'all going to fucking know him crazy and I just tell them that they good keys.
The good kids now. Oh they know I fuck them up.
I have a lot of bits about him because like the stuff like I do this bit about,
I used to do this bit about the teacher's school calling me all the time.
White schools call you for anything and anything, Joe. I mean, just dumb shit.
Black schools. We told them, look bitch,
that's your child to two 30 don't you wake me up? So one of the,
one of the beats I used to tell, they call me by my niece Yolanda,
because she was sitting in the crayon table with her little white friends and
they're talking about their daddies. So Yolanda said, what?
The next time I see my daddy, I'm going to stab him in the neck.
And all the white kids started crying and they asked me to come up there and
emergency. They come up there to talk to them. I get up there, I'm like, ma'am,
she can't stab her dead. And then nick, the N***a in jail,
somebody was going to stab him in the knee.
Don't wake me up if I don't wake me up for this bullshit.
So they don't know how to handle anything. And I had to set the school down.
I said, look, these kids are from the hood.
They only talked and do what they know.
You gotta give me time to help them grow.
But then they wanted to put them on medication. I said what? We will, yeah,
because they didn't know how to deal with them. They had this so, so much like,
hey mama was into horn and that was in drugs that they were beating on her mom
and they, they, they didn't know how to handle them. And I say, look,
we're going to help him grow together. I said, well what we not going to do,
we're not going to put these kids on medication.
What we gonna do is surround them with love. They so good now out of five years,
this baby just now passing the ice step test. They took a minute to get there.
But he's finally there step those public,
those standardized tests they give kids and the kids just wasn't ready and you
know, I throw him in his neighborhood,
threw him in an environment that they wasn't used to and then you know,
they talk their language.
You see how a country I am when they talk straight streets.
Cause sometimes like what the fuck are y'all talking about?
We bout it bout another fuck. You Ain't getting better set at five bucks.
You Cross your head. Yeah, they ready to rumble.
They ready to fight the little boy like I'm bout about,
I said put your fucking finger down, fire breaking.
But I had to retrain him because what he saw in the hood,
it wasn't going at my nice little white school. No, they're adapting.
They're good now. They're good at it. Imagine all the kids that don't,
and you can imagine because it was you and all the kids who don't have someone
like you. Well, my niece is 20 years old,
21 and she's six kids and she in jail for 20 years for knocking on people's door
and robbing them so her kids is in a situation.
So just imagine all the kids. I think about it all the time,
especially when it's my family member, but Joe, I had to realize this.
I can't say the world. You can't save everybody.
I tried to save one at a time and that's all I can do. That's all you can do.
Yeah, that is all you can do. I can't say it a world. I mean,
I can't live if I keep trying to say the world.
No. Well, you won't be able to do what you're doing. That's helping people too.
One of the things you're doing and it's helping people is you making people
laugh. Yeah. I mean that, that helps a lot. Yeah.
People fucking need that.
They need it so bad and so many people right now with their headphones on in
their cubicle laughing their ass off right now. I hope so. Fuck yeah,
they need it.
[inaudible] pet down Joe road that for sure they're going to subscribe.
I guarantee you. I hope so. 100%
you know,
I was doing a show last night at the verge of here in La and a man came up to me
, said, man, my dog died today and I've been crying all day,
but I want to tell you how much you helped me fucking relieve. I said, well,
I'm sorry about your dog. Did you burn him up?
He actually started laughing, you know, after they die,
you got to them cremate or cream in them. Excellent.
We actually started laughing, but I'm,
I mean I get that all the time and you know, laughter is what he ought mean.
When I was able, when I was able to write my book and you know,
started doing comedy,
especially like it was one story now about my mama boyfriend who molest me. And,
um, I had never told this door over 30 something years.
My husband and no only person knows me and my sister cause he's all,
we happen to us at the same time with him. And, um, I never told this door.
And I remember when I was writing my book, The lady who co-wrote my book,
she was like, uh, you gotta tell the store. And I said, well,
I got to ask my sister and I get my sister on the phone, Joe. And I was like,
may pop devil's on, it's a name. I say, you ready to tell what Mr John did?
And we both did as Boohoo, Eh, we cheat.
We told some of the store,
we got off the phone and it took for me to tell his story. Took almost a week.
Me and the writer cries so much cause I had, I had all of that built up in me.
But I'm so happy I was able to tell that story now because that was the only
story I had never told public about how my mama boyfriend did.
Me and my sister from the age of probably six or eight ty was 11 years old cause
I started, my kid's father was 21 and I was 12 and I made him.
So I started having six at 12 so when he started touching me my,
when I got a boyfriend, my momma, my momma boyfriend left us alone.
Once you got a boyfriend? Yeah, once I got a boyfriend, Jesus Christ.
So that was the only store I had never told.
But when I told him I felt like I lost 20 I'm probably a hundred pounds.
I felt like it, but it didn't go anywhere. Right. But I just felt a relief.
Yeah. So I know loud, I just know Lotta does a lot for me.
So I know it does the same for other people. God Damn,
you've had a crazy fucking life. And I laugh at every inch of it too.
Well it's, that's the only way you can, I mean, what you've done is, I mean,
you've done the ultimate take a negative and turn it into a positive. I try.
I try really hard. But you mean you really have because your,
your sense of humor is so fucked
up because of your life that it's so fun. I mean,
that's why it works.
If you had a cushy life and you were saying the shit that you say,
it wouldn't be funny.
So it wouldn't be. No, and that's one of the things with my husband,
like when I was sharing with them, like my kid's father shot me and beat me.
You know, most of your listeners in Canada, who I am, they know my background.
And one of the things when I started sharing my life,
my husband had their protective Mo. He didn't want me to, you know,
he knew how negative the world could be when I started to share these stories so
I could see what he wanted to step in and protect me. Right. You know,
when people would judge me. And you know,
like I dropped out of school in eighth grade when my husband went to the
military, went on off and he had a mommy and daddy are way better life than me.
So he would always be there to like be that protector, like, Oh,
they think I'm stupid. [inaudible] and I just, I just,
he helped me grow a backbone to, you'd say, fuck what people think about you.
Give me, cause it was so most screwed up stuff in my head. Like, uh, um,
one of the thing my Mama taught me about white people,
like I didn't deal with white people. I mean, let's be honest,
I'm from the hood. There was a police on the fucking on the case worker.
My Mama told me, she said,
why people are better than you and they will look them in the fucking devil.
So my whole life, Joe Rogan, I was scared of white people. And when I,
when I wrote the book and I told The lady this, when I was see white people,
I immediately looked down, well that's what the slaves used to do.
And that's what the book lady taught me and I was like,
I can't look them in eye. And then she was like, why not?
I told her the story and I told my husband stories. He say, Pat,
he say we're all the same. Your fucking Mama is stupid.
I used to tell a bit, I said,
the only difference between me and you white woman is my titties is bigger than
yours. But I was in,
I was in my late twenties when I learned it because you like I,
when I moved to Indianapolis I couldn't talk to you a fucking,
my words will stump and I will immediately say I'm stupid and I will look away.
And when I started doing coming in Indianapolis and my fan base turn white and I
was like, why the fuck y'all like me? Get away from me, cop the shit out of you.
I say that to myself and my husband sent me down and was like,
pet we all the same. Your fucking mom is stupid. I'm like, we are.
And I was in my late twenties I had never ever dealt with white people.
Like I dealt with them when I moved into that community.
And I'm glad because it taught me a lot as a young girl out at it,
out of the inner state of Atlanta, that we are all the same.
The problem with to problem with this country is we don't fucking talk. Yeah,
no communication. Well
there's that. And then there's the, these communities stay the way they are.
Like whether it's Baltimore where they had it set up or black people literally
weren't allowed to buy homes outside of certain areas or any inner city like you
know,
in inner city in Houston or in New York or anywhere where the neighborhoods stay
the same, they stay the same [inaudible] generation. Yeah. Crime, poverty,
all the drugs, everything stays the same. And it does, you know,
so my kids, my kids are fucking,
they blessings and they don't realize how blessed they are.
And sometimes I get so pissed off at them.
Like they go to this really nice high school where I live in Indiana and they
get they little laptops and you know, they get new books every fucking year.
Joe, when I went to school, it was so many niggles, name Roland,
that same book where it had and checked it out every year you had to flip a page
and you'll see Ramon Tyrone's. I got three pages of kids who had that book
and it pisses me off because you know, I look at it and I was like, well,
this is the old curriculum where you know,
these my kids are getting a new curriculum every year and it's still like that
in certain parts of America and it pisses me off. I'm like, yeah,
you guys don't realize how blessed you are.
You come in through a fucking this fucking thousand dollars,
pay it on a float at this school and gave you, take Schiff grand.
Like my daughter will literally hold up the school bus because she wanted to
walk slow because she was fat. So the lady called me and was like, Ms Pat,
every day I gotta wait on Gary Ana to get on the bus.
And I've asked her several times to be at the bus stop when I get there.
And I said, ma'am, lead that bitch
leaver you lead that motherfucker. She'll get down on time but you know you,
you did. They Pamper on me in my neighborhood.
I said don't you dare pepper my black key lead that bitch cause I'll leave you
ain't you ain't in the car when I get in the car bitch buy
bag my kid. No you've got to get in the car phone momma cause she'll leave you.
I fuck you. You want to school.
I mean my daughter would come in the house one time and say I need you to take
me to stop books. I'm like, why cool kids come to school with Starbucks. I said,
bitch, you buy golden school. You better. I said, it's night. I said, you crazy.
If you think I'm gonna get up at six o'clock in the morning to take you to
Starbucks, you better take your feathers to Starbucks at night.
And get you a cup and put you some hot chocolate in the morning. I'm not going,
I'm not getting up at no six o'clock to make you cool. But they do that.
Yes. The standard thing. Come bring me my lunch. I left my [inaudible].
I tell my kids if you leave something,
you didn't fucking want it cause I'm in the bed with no wig and no broughten
yesterday puts it. I'm not getting up yesterday's post. Yeah.
Well how's that work?
Because I went to bed last night and they ain't washed it before.
They called me yesterday pussy. So I'm not getting up you crazy as hell.
I'm not nobody. Nobody gave me nothing.
They understand that no one gave you anything like hell yeah, they get it.
They get it. Yeah, they get it. But they was like, no,
I don't want to hear y'all. You're poor stories. No listen
days, Ma, my cable. Thank you. My cable got cut off one day. Right.
So I go in the House on my cable, cut off and I tell him us, I was like,
did you pay the fucking kb and my hose? Oh my God, I forgot to pay the cable.
Go turn the cable on before the kids get home. I was like, fuck these kids.
You know how many time I had to look at a father TV and thought it was snowing?
I'm like, I'm not going. I'm so, I'm going to bed. Fuck the kids.
I don't care about the kids, but he broke his neck to pay. TheK will be uncles.
He don't want the kids to ever know what is light and not have light gas on
what? Fuck d g they fat. They can miss a couple meal. Joe,
I didn't cut that cable back on, but he broke his knee. He did.
He came home and cut it all out. I don't, I don't go out the way for you.
I love you, but I tell you I don't love you like Jesus.
Do He love you on condition? I was stabbed the shit out of you.
I loan my kids money. You got to pay me back. My daughter called me. She said,
can I borrow $3,000 a bitch? You got the wrong number. 3000 yeah,
to buy her a car. I don't got nothing to do with that. She, I got my car, Joe,
my car paid off. I drive a little old layers.
Cruel that McCracken [inaudible] crack it. Knees left. I bought for her.
That's what I drive every day. My Shit paid off. I'm not buying, you know, call.
Well Bitch, I use on my phone bill for three years.
He never paid your phone bill. So how are you going to pay me back 3000 now.
What did she say to that? I call you back. I said, I bet
this is my money. I wrote off it is money.
I know you were dealt when I was selling Craig and forging checks,
but you had jaws and nice sheet.
I don't know that your life was hard,
but if you had to live it over again, I mean what?
I mean it made you who you are. That will change about thing. Yeah,
that's what I was going to ask you.
But it's all fucked up thing to ask someone when they tell you they were
molested by your mom's boyfriend and that, you know,
you had a,
a baby with this guy when you were 14 and he's married and then another one and
by the time you're 16, you're pregnant with a third. Yeah, no, no problem.
Whatever. Right? Selling crack and shot in the tet,
no one would ever ask you to live that life again, but you,
you wouldn't change it.
Ah, I don't know Joe. I mean it made me who I am, but I always,
I look at life like this. Um, I think I would, you know,
everybody couldn't have dealt with the stuff that I dealt with it.
Like I dealt with it like some people commit suicide complaint when people
always depressed, you know, I kind of feel like I was the chosen one.
God take you through something so it can, you know, to make other people see,
maybe I was poor,
maybe I took burden that everybody else was going through in life and now I was
the chosen one. Then I bring it out and make it funny.
So I'm here to make people let, let people know it's okay. Yeah, it's okay.
It's not about how you start as about how you finish. Right.
I don't dwell on shit. I don't have control over. I can't change the pace.
But Liz left today and I tell people every night on stage when you can laugh
about it, you got control of it.
That's a powerful thing to be able to look at your life like that and just take
ownership. Yeah. You know, like my first kid's father, he hates me.
He fucking hates me. You know why?
Because I'm not that little girl rabbit anymore that he had control of that he
beat any, you know,
I was a little girl searching for love in this whole situation.
I learned to love myself. Joe, do you still in touch with him? Yeah.
Talk to him. He be cussing me. He's like, he's not in jail. Yeah,
that's what I be telling him. I'm like, dude, I'm not a child molester.
I remember when I needed closure and um, I was,
I was out here in La and I'm out.
I'm starting to tell these stories about my life and I just wanted him to
apologize for you. Only shot him in the back of the head.
Fucking beat me crazy.
So I wanted him to apologize and my, I was like,
why do you need him to apologize? I just want to hear it.
I just want to tell you rabbit. I'm sorry. So I call him up and I said, Daryl,
we started talk. Oh Shit. I said his name. Oh, okay.
So I call him and I ask him to apologize. And He, I said, I said,
how can you fuck a 12 year old and you grown and you mayor,
you know what he said? He said,
your mind and body wasn't 12 and that she kicked me in my fucking chest like a
horse and I boohoo and debt day Joe,
I decided I was no longer going to ask him to ask for you took, you know,
to ask me to forgive him. I decided to forgive him. I forgave my momma.
I forgave my mama boyfriend and everybody else that stepped on me.
And I said, no longer am I'm ever gonna want to come gonna come.
I know I say from that day on,
I'm never gonna ask Y'all for forget. I'm never gonna ask you again. Um,
I decided to forgive you. And that day I forgave him,
my mom and her boyfriend and everybody else that ever violated me.
Cause it was so many other people that I don't still don't talk about,
but I forgave him. That's a very powerful thing and I'm happy.
It's a very powerful thing if you can forgive people who've done terrible things
to you and you haven't done shit to them. Yeah.
The people that want them to apologize, they chased them, they checked the,
you're eating yourself up, you eating yourself.
And I was eating myself up cause I just wanted him to say I'm sorry, rabbit.
And he never said it. Well once he told you that when you were 12, your mind,
your body weren't young. You got to realize you're talking to them.
Fucking idiot. Idiot. And I called my husband and I was crying. He was like,
pat, why do you keep, I said, I just want him to ask me too.
I just want him to say he, sorry. That's all I want him to say. And he was like,
Pat, why?
And I remember hanging out the phone and I got on my knees and I rarely get on
my knees. Joe and I got vertigo so I don't get on
and you know what I'm talking about. So I just, I asked for forgiveness. I mean,
I forgave him that day. I forgave him and my Mama, because of him,
my mom and her boyfriend, John,
is three of the people that I hated the most because she didn't protect me.
And when we once tried to tell her that her boyfriend was doing that to us,
you know, he wouldn't listen.
She wouldn't listen because this man was providing,
it was the only time in my life that we didn't get evicted because he was
touching me and my sister, he was always saying, well,
if you tell your momma y'all gonna get pulled out,
y'all ain't gonna have no food. So we always thought we was happen.
We always thought we was happen. So you know what?
I forgave him and then you know, they was day was already dead,
but he's still alive. He's still my kid.
His father is still alive or you want to know something crazy.
And I never told anybody this. So people always like,
why you don't go to your Mama grave site?
You know a lot of people like I don't like fucking with the dead.
I figured they want to raise leaving the fuck alone.
They don't want to hear about the love legal, the lively shit.
I don't go to her grave y'all,
because that motherfucker put herself next to her.
Wow.
Barrett himself next to my Mama. So I said, fuck both of you.
I'm not going up there. He's laying right next to her.
Wow.
Last time I was there before he died,
I was there cleaning off some ants on top of a gray. And you know, I'm young,
I'm probably,
she died when I was 16 probably 1617 I go out there with a gas can pull it on
top of the light it on fire to get the NBN. I'm finally sitting home.
It's a curry. The ants.
You bought jazz on it, lit it on fire. Jesus. Fuck.
Oh my God, I haven't been back. Jealous.
I haven't been back. No need to go back. I won't go back. He's next door,
so he wanted their controls or he got it. Fuck them. I'm never going back.
God Damn has pad everything. Every time I talk to you,
I think I've heard it all.
Oh Shit. Joe, we needed, give me the mom some olive oil and wine.
I can tell you a hundred another fucking store. What one? Olive. God,
God. Oh yes. I love that shit.
I drink a glass a day and I tell you a million fucking stuff.
I was telling a story.
I just started writing a bit about how my Mama used to was a crap shooter and
propose she shoot a dice.
She was locked up for five kids and she would rub them on our vagina upon our
tea. That was good. Look for her.
She would rub the dice on your vagina and your titties probably dies.
All you post it for good luck. How old were you? Probably at fat.
Oh my God. What the fuck?
I don't want to tell the whole story cause I just wrote a Viet about it so yo,
wake up. It's the fucking bitch. It's fucking hilarious.
You're not going to do it tonight? No, I'm not going to do it at night.
It's not all the way down. But boy,
when I got my friends like pay you gotta be like I said, I call my brother.
I said both. That's my oldest brother. He biracial, right?
We say my mom say we got same day but didn't move a got good hails. Well,
we know. We know that. They ain't know Jerry Carolyn.
So I said, bow your loan. Do you remember when Mama used to shoot dice?
She's like, yeah, she's [inaudible] my mother fucking no, sorry.
Okay.
My friends like, Oh, you know some shit when black people go like, Woo, fuck
great.
Oh my God, I can't breathe. Well,
fuck up. You Thought, Oh my God, I'm crying breeze.
Holy Shit. God Damn is pat.
And then I'll still laugh. I love to laugh. I fucking love it. I know you do.
You make people laugh. You want to funniest people I've ever met. Wow. Thank you
to fact.
Fuck what a life you had. God dammit.
It's so hard to listen to as a person who has kids. You know,
it's so hard to think about you being a little girl having to go through that
and you know it used to people say, Oh pat, you should get counseling.
But honestly comedy has been my counseling. It is a bit,
is a form of counseling for sure. I was able to share with shit that I had.
I was anger about, I'm no longer angry and making people laugh. I'm naked. Look,
I'm fucking crying. I'm literally crying.
Yeah. And you know,
then you meet so many people who can have a story like you people.
I was always pet. You're telling my story. Thank you so much.
I had a black lady tell me one time, she was like,
I had my baby at 13 how can you talk about that? I said, cause bitch,
I'm happy and my child didn't have the life that I hate you,
so I'm happy. You know what I only thing I asked when my keys, I said,
I asked you college ain't for everybody so I'm not going to force college on
you, but what you do owe me is a high school diploma or you do owe me the prom
because I didn't have an opportunity to do none of that shit.
So all of them go to the pro. Alan went to the Prom,
I pick that outfit and everyone of them graduated from high school,
you know out my daughter was the first one in three generations to graduate high
school and the first one to ever go to college. Then she didn't finish.
But Hey man did my, my youngest daughter just finished criminal justice.
You have associate's degree and you know every time they do it they lot,
I'm going to the prom for you. They can graduate high school.
They gave me the high school diploma. My daughter was like, oh,
well I just graduated from college. Your Hago your degree.
Okay.
I was like, bitch, you Kolodny or whatever. Fuck it is.
You know what I'm talking about? Straight A's. Yes. Gulati. Yeah,
that's what she was, you was good Laurie. So I mean she didn't,
she didn't go to her well
graduation, she's, she, she didn't want to go on to graduation.
So she booked it. She, she had two options. So she booked it on a day.
I was out of town, but she grew up, she's my first child.
He graduated college and I look back,
here I am with the eighth grade education or the GED and I was able to keep my
keys from going on the road that I went down. And you know, most, most,
most kids try to make their parents proud.
I try to make my kids proud to let them know it's not about how you start,
it's about how you finish. You know, I had to,
I had to meet to my oldest daughter and I said,
George will front house school and I in, you know,
I had to wake her up at one time and I said,
I want to apologize for being such a horrible mom in the beginning,
but I was fucking 14 you know, she was in housing. What a hit. [inaudible].
She saw me sell drugs in front of her school. I said,
I made a lot of fucking mistakes, but I'm sorry,
because I did what everybody else was doing in my community trying to survive.
And that was one of the hardest thing as a parent because a lot of parents high,
you know, their past when they kid. But I literally went to my daughter and I,
you know, cause she hated me. Joe, she fucking hated me. She's like,
why do you have to sell drugs in front of my school? I said,
cause I was here first bitch.
But you know, I think, you know, we, we have, we have a relationship now,
you know, and then I went off to jail and I missed her going to kindergarten.
And then I grew up in a community where if he was gay,
something was wrong with you. You know, my daughter, she gets fuck,
he eat everything in Atlanta. She packed man with the Pussy.
So, you know, I had to,
I had to deal with that too because she ran off for a while when she,
when she wouldn't, you know, when I, she didn't want to tell me she was gay.
Cause I mean I had this thing where if you gave with some roach,
I fucking hated gay women. And I, I,
I used to say this on stage when I say white men, when you, when you,
when you hate N****s as a good chance,
your white daughter gonna come home with a big dig Nagel
and open your foot.
My daughter came home and she was gate and it opened my fucking world to the gay
community. And now like I remember when my daughter came out and some,
I was like,
you must be ashamed that your daughter's guessed [inaudible] your daughter's a
whole. So your daughter going to take way more dicks than my daughter do. Okay.
Immediately. I love my daughter, I love all of my kids and in,
and I told Ashley, that's her name. I said, it's not about, I had to learn,
it's not about your sexuality, do what make you happy.
And I will support you to the end as long as you happy because you saw your
daddy stopped my face and shoot me and ms treat me.
So if we were to do what makes you happy, just don't do drugs, bitch,
but do what? Make you happy. What? What made you not like gay women before that?
Cause I was raised in the black community. If you was gay, you know,
we're the biggest motherfucker. Black people who would throw up a gay child.
I'll tell you something wrong, which we talked to hate, you know,
especially that old school, black community. That's why. So you know people,
you know, I don't know Joe. That's just how we was raised.
The black church drilling in your head, you know, if you gay,
you're going to hell. And you know your mom.
What happens with gay people in the Bar Community?
A lot of them leave and never come back back in the day.
A lot of them wait til they, you know, they fucking mental problems.
I don't know. Like I didn't, I don't remember gay uncle anybody.
So, but you know, I know we as a black community, you have to hide.
You had to hide making those days.
So I was taught if he was gay it was you was, it was something wrong with you.
And when my daughter came out to be gay,
it opened my fucking world up and I was like,
do I judge my daughter over sexuality or do I love my child because this is my
fucking child. And I remember not seeing her for three years. She just running,
she had dropped out of college and she has gone from state to state them,
they're homeless, a lot of them be homeless. And I said, look Ashley,
I said, are you gay? I just want to hear it for myself. She was like, yes ma'am.
I said well come on home you he puts it in Atlanta. Yeah.
And my child came home
and we built a relationship and I hadn't, you know,
I was wrong out cause she her how I talked about gay people and how it's almost
like when you hear your boy, if you, if you want to hear your parents,
I wasn't N***a, N***a, N***a, N***a, N***a. Then you want to know wisely.
We talking about N***a you get curious and you go outside and like it ain't what
you think it is. So when she came out and you know she,
when she came out he opened my world and I'm happy.
I'm happy for my baby and I tell her about my daughter will eat the shit out of
you. She would dick you down once grandpa.
But she happy Joe and this what is all about,
you know that's all we lock in that all I asked is that she get a bitch.
They treat her right that she's a whole rent now.
But you know new girl every six months. What is new girl she got,
she had been sticking with her for a long ago.
I liked the last girlfriend we saw big bigfoot,
but she got rid of big foot foot. If she was a boy,
she would play professional baseball.
Oh, bigger feet, big old beach,
big beach run. Oh, he's taller than Lebron James,
but I liked her aligned with new girls.
Fringy growing. Oh me. So what is all about being happy
all about being happy you, you've, you've done an amazing thing with your life.
Thank you. You took terrible beginning and turns it into an amazing present.
You know, you're one of the funniest people. I swear to God,
you one of the funniest people I've ever met.
You're a a like a big time professional comedian. People love you. I mean,
I think what you've done is amazing to,
to come where you started from and to be who you are now. That's, it's amazing.
Thank you. I mean, and I tell people, I tell them I'm a convicted felon.
They ain't shit does. I can do either you laugh or rob, you did not.
It's not just that you had a hard life,
you had a hard life and you worked hard to become a great comment.
Well, I had a hard life and I wanted to say my kids in the beginning,
I just didn't want my kids to go through what I went through.
So that was the biggest fire. I was like,
y'all ain't sticking your thumb and my Babe ass hole that I'm sorry y'all ain't
gonna do that to my children. Why do you not going to jail?
You're not going to drop out. You know? I just,
I just wanted my kids to have shit did I never had,
which was a life, you know? And then my, and then, you know,
one thing in my book is about, I, I was searching for something.
I wanted a family. I never had a family. I never felt love. Like I feel today,
you know, I got a family. I go home to a husband and see me two times a week,
but he's still fucking love me even though he say not at all.
He's being funny. Yeah. He being funny, but I know him loved Joe. Yeah,
I him him. I never had that as a child. I knew I, when my, I planned vacation,
they'd be like, oh, we gotta do that. Fuck hell, we got to do this. Do you know?
You want to know what it is to be without a family fucking Mama we going,
which we won't. He won't. We don't want to hear these horrible stories.
When I booked that Disney crew,
they was all pissed off and they had a fucking ball and it was 22 of us when we
was there as a family and that's all.
I don't care to go when I go take him to the lake or take him.
I don't care to participate. I just want to know. I just look at him and say,
Oh my God, I got what I fought for my whole fucking life.
A family to be loved and I'm love Joe. That's beautiful.
Then that's all I ever wanted. I don't give a fuck about the fancy call.
I care about the nice weeks. But
listen, you and Junebug, you're going to start this youtube series, I promise,
work out together, and then the pat down is available on iTunes,
available everywhere. Your book, it's still out there.
It's doing really well yet.
It's called rabbit rabbit nominated for the NAACP Image Award,
and we're working tonight tonight, comedy store. Thank you. Thank you.
God Damn. That was funny.
[inaudible].